tristan hat natürlich gerade bielefeld
sehr hart getroffen und diese
schattenseiten des ja dieses
schneesturms zeichnen sich natürlich
hier genau ab wie du gerade schon
erwähnt hat das wurde heute morgen hier
eine leiche gefunden und ich bin jetzt
hier bei der polizei in bielefeld neben
mir steht polizei-pressesprecher herr
trümper vielleicht könnten sie einmal
genaueres zu den verletzten also ich
kann ihnen bestätigen dass wir heute
morgen gegen halb neun in bielefeld eine
männliche leiche aufgefunden haben in
der artur ladebeck straße konnte der
eingesetzte notarzt dann leider nur noch
den tod feststellen
nach jetzigem kenntnisstand gehen wir
davon aus dass es sich um einen
internistischen notfall gehandelt hat
unsere fachdienststelle ist aber dennoch
dran die ermittlungen laufen in diesem
bereich noch und von daher können wir
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt aber keine
genaueren angaben machen
also ein kältetod kann man zurzeit noch
nicht bestätigen
das können wir nicht bestätigen dann
laufen die ermittlungen noch an dieser
stelle aber vielleicht mal ganz kurze
hinweis oder auch der appell wenn sie
das einmal erlauben
die nachttemperaturen gefallen in
zweistellige minusgrade da bitten wir
einfach die bevölkerung aufeinander zu
achten auch auf obdachlose insbesondere
vielleicht mal zu achten und das was
bielefeld auszeichnet nehme ich das gute
miteinander
sollte ich auch weiter gepflegt werden
dass wir einfach ein bisschen auf unsere
mitmenschen beachten und gerade in
diesen eiskalten nächten unserem hilfe
kümmern das ist doch in diesem fall dann
als minister
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren